en ukraine on continue à en parler à
bout de chats dans la banlieue de kiev
ville théâtre de massacres imputés à
l'armée russe la vie reprend
progressivement depuis le départ des
troupes russes fin mars sur place on va
retrouver tout de suite du livre craag
notre correspondant
aujourd'hui le centre de boudhha est
vraiment très animé il y a beaucoup de
magasins ouverts dont ce supermarché
derrière moi qui est relativement bien
fournit maintenant même si certains
habitants se plaignent qu il n'y a pas
assez de produits dans les magasins
qu'il y à des queues encore un tract est
énorme si on compare à la scène ici
début avril juste après le départ des
forces russes à ce moment là il y avait
pratiquement que les gens qui étaient
restés qui avaient subi le cauchemar de
l'occupation russe à abuja il n'y avait
pas d'électricité les gens cuisinent et
dans leurs cours pour la plupart d'entre
eux ils avaient passé la plupart des ces
semaines de l'occupation russe dans des
sous sols à se cacher des bombardements
une partie de boudhha est très
endommagée mais en réalité c'est plutôt
irp in et au sommet les villes voisines
qui ont le plus souffert en termes de
dommages mais des bâtiments de
l'infrastructure le centre-ville de
boudhha est intact mais volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien estime
le coût ne serait ce que en termes
d'infrastructures ukrainienne à plus de
600 milliards de dollars pour les seuls
trois mois r il y a un coût énorme un
effort de reconstruction qui prendra
bien plus de temps que ces opérations de
nettoyage du centre de bouddha qui sont
très impressionnants et qui ont été
faits en l'espace de quelques semaines
seulement bien sûr
pour qui
soulagement et l'optimisme quant aux
chances de l'ukraine de gagner
éventuellement cette guerre il est un
grand traumatisme qu'il faudra beaucoup
de temps pour guérir et aussi
l'inquiétude pour le sort des ukrainiens
qui sont aujourd'hui sous occupation
russe dans le sud et dans l'est du pays
et qui surtout dans l'est dans la région
du donbass subissent aussi les offensifs
russes les combats les batailles
d'artillerie qui font rage dans cette
région alors que les russes semblent
bien déterminés toujours à prendre le
contrôle de la totalité des régions de
donetsk est lougansk eux qui composent
le donbass notamment la ville de
severodonetsk semble être la cible
principale pour le moment de cette
offensive russe mais les experts
militaires ukrainiens sont convaincus
que ce n'est qu'une question de temps
avant que l'ukraine commence à monter
des consos contre offensive dans l'est
de l'ukraine aussi l'espoir bien sûr est
que l'ukraine arrivera à chasser les
forces russes du donbass comme elle a pu
chasser les forces russes de la région
de kiev et du nord de l'ukraine fin mars
début avril